Let's start our discussion with the world's most
simplest and naive implementation of the lock, and we're
calling it spinlock because, as you're going to see a
processor that is waiting for lock has to spin,
in order to spin, meaning, doing no useful work,
but it is waiting for the lock to be
released. And the first one that we're going to look
at, is what is called spin on testing set.
The idea is very simple and straightforward. There's
a shared memory location, L and it can
have one of two possible values. Either unlocked
or locked. And let's say that at the.
at the beginning, we've initialized unlocked, so nobody
has the lock. And the way to implement
this naive spinlock algorithm is the following. What
you do is, you go in and check,
using test and set primitive, the memory location, L. So when you call this lock
primitive the lock primitive executes this Instruction
testant set of L, and what that is
going to do is, its going to return the old value from L, and set it to
the new value which is locked, that's going to
be done automatically, we that from the architecture,
that it is going to provide you that, that is a primitive, and so
now, if we find that this test and and set,
instruction execution returns the value locked, it means that somebody else
has bought the lock. And therefore, I cannot
use it and i'm going to basically spin here. That's
why its called spin on test and set,
so you're basically spinning waiting for this test and
set instruction to return to me. A value that says, the
old value is unlocked. If I, if it gives me, the old
value is unlocked, then I know I won. But if I
don't, then I, basically, I'm going to wait here. That's why it's called
spinning on test and set. So let's put up some threads
here that are trying to get this lock. And, so let's say
that T 1 is the first one to make a test and
set call on this lock, and it finds it unlocked, and therefore,
it locks it. And once it locks it, T1 knows
that it's got the lock. So, it's got the lock, it
can go off to messing with the data structure that
it wants to mess with, and that is good. So far
as T1 is concerned. In the meanwhile, T2 and T3
may come along and say well, we also want the lock,
and they also execute the same lock algorithm. And when
they execute the lock algorithm, they're going to do the Test-and-Set and
you know that the Test-and-Set when they do that, the
old value that is going to be returned for T2 or
T3 is going to be that the value L is locked
and therefore these two guys, both T2 and T3 are stuck
here. How long are they going to be stuck? Until this
guy releases the lock, and the way to do that
is very simple. So he comes along and calls an
unlock function, and what the unlock function does, is it basically
goes in, and clears this lock. Meaning it
resets this lock to the unlocked state. And, and
so once it does that, then this lock becomes
available. So, it becomes unlocked and at this point,
T2 and T3 were stuck here. When they
tried to do this testing set again, they're going to
find, at least one of them hopefully exactly one
of them, is going to find that, that the lock
is unlocked and therefore they're going to get it.
And one of them will get it, and,
will, will go on to executing whatever code
they want to do, and the protection of the
lock, and so only exactly one of T2 or T3 will win, because that's a semantic
of test and set. So that's the world's
simplest lock algorithm, spinning on test and set.